jersey shore star ronnie ortiz-magro has
been arrested
a rep for the los angeles police
department confirms that the reality
star was arrested in los
angeles on thursday and released the
same day on 100 000
bail et can confirm that he was arrested
on a felony charge
and according to multiple reports the
charge is suspicion of domestic violence
in a statement to e.t ronnie's attorney
said quote
we have just learned of the new
allegations against ronnie and need some
additional time to further investigate
as such we will not be making any other
statements at this time
you know i take one day one step at a
time the 35 year old was previously
arrested for alleged domestic violence
in october 2019.
he was also tased by police during his
arrest
taken to a local hospital before getting
booked in a nearby jail
he was later released on 100 000 bail
i put myself in certain situations but
it's how you come
out of the situation is what you do at
the end ronnie avoided being hit with
the felony charges over the incident
after the los angeles district
attorney's office deferred the case to
the los angeles city attorney a few
weeks later
the la city attorney revealed to e.t at
the time that they would be pursuing
multiple misdemeanor charges against the
reality star including one count of
domestic violence
one count of brandishing a weapon or a
firearm one count of child endangerment
and one count of criminal threats court
documents obtained by e.t at the time
also showed he faced a charge of false
imprisonment
and an additional count of resisting
arrest one for each
officer whom he allegedly resisted
ronnie later pleaded not guilty to the
seven misdemeanors in november 2019.
things you do you do and it's how you
come out of it it wasn't until may 2020
that ronnie struck a plea deal with the
city attorney
pleading no contest to one count of
domestic battery
and one count of resisting arrest
instead of
jail time he received 36 months of
probation which he is still serving
you guys have seen the worst parts of me
the best parts of me
the worst part so it's like why not just
keep it going and in january 2020
amid his tumultuous relationship with
on-again off-again girlfriend jen harley
he was granted an emergency restraining
order against her
the two share a three-year-old daughter
ariana together
and when eti caught up with ronnie in
2019
he opened up about holding himself
accountable for his on-screen
and off-screen behavior every decision
that i make you know i have to realize
that i have a daughter now
you know and a lot of things that you do
on tv and a lot of things you say like
especially our show it's so popular that
eventually she's gonna see it
you know and it's you know you got to be
careful with the way you act and the way
he thinks because it's going to portray
to her and then she has to grow up with
that you know because at the end of the
day she's the ones walking around like
that's my dad or that's my mom so
it's a really it's a lot of pressure
you